hey youtubers it's Charlie so the CW has
cast their Vandal Savage he's gonna
appear on the flash arrow and legends of
tomorrow he's the big bad for legends of
tomorrow but he's gonna debut and like
the big flash versus arrow crossover
this year that's gonna be Episode eight
of both those shows remember legends of
tomorrow doesn't start till January
whenever arrow and flash come back what
I'm expecting is is because they have
like a bunch of new legends of tomorrow
characters that they're gonna introduce
on the flash and arrow and like the
first half of the season is that they'll
refer to Vandal Savage like we'll hear
about him but supposedly we're not gonna
see him like physically see him on
screen till that big crossover episode
the actor that they cast is named Casper
Crump I'm not super familiar with him he
definitely looks the part but he's that
he's a Danish actor so if you're in the
UK you're probably a little more
familiar with him than everyone else now
they've also cast Hawkman but I'm gonna
do a separate video for him this is
mostly about Vandal Savage but his name
is Faulk Henschel you might be a little
more familiar with him he's had small
parts in really big movies like White
House down and transcendence so you may
have seen him before
we've already met Hawkgirl of course so
Hawkman was actually a big surprise for
me I'll talk a little bit more about him
during that video but because the
foundation of the show is built on time
travel they're gonna visit multiple
really big events in DC's comic book
history so naturally we're probably
going to see Hawkman and Hawkgirl
get reincarnated the entire story isn't
about them but I mean we'll probably
visit stuff like the flash crisis that
they teased in that future newspaper
even though that only started out as an
Easter Egg originally whenever they did
the flash pilot that was just like a fun
thing that they were doing is a wink to
the audience but on to Vandal Savage
everybody starts swirling a glass of
wine in a really sinister way so Vandal
Savage probably one of the biggest DC
villains that we haven't seen in a
live-action TV show in like in a major
way
Dean Cain did play a version of the
character on Smallville but at the last
minute when they were getting ready to
actually shoot the episode Warner
Brothers was like nope you can't you
can't use that Vandal Savage name so
unofficially Vandal Savage has been on
TV there's all the animated movies of
course - he's been in a lot of Justice
League animated stuff people always
wonder about how that fits in with the
live-action stuff the animated stuff
that they've done before isn't canon the
exception to that is now vixen the vixen
series that they're doing six episodes
for that's going to be a tie-in with
arrow and the flash in that universe so
whenever they bring vandals
the arrow and flash though completely
explained his history the narrative will
assume that he hasn't been around in the
universe before so that'll explain his
existence like how is it that you're
immortal and we haven't heard about you
before arrow did the same thing with
Rachel Ghul and damian darhk-- we follow
Oliver and Barry as they learn about all
these big villains his comic book
readers though we already know like all
these villains all these storylines how
they play out most of the storylines
that Vandal Savage has had the biggest
storylines are just a society now it's
weird that they're not calling legends
of tomorrow just to society even though
that's kind of what the show is
but I'm suspecting that Warner Brothers
didn't want them to use it because
they're developing some other just a
society TV show that should speculation
though they haven't announced anything
like that just to explain his powers you
may know that he's immortal but he is
roughly fifty thousand years old as an
adult he was exposed to quote-unquote
mysterious radiation from a meteor and
stopped aging you know cut to fifty
thousand years later but he's been
around for the entirety of human history
so he's like the guy behind the guy you
have like damian darhk-- the
reverse-flash like all these big big
villains they're like darth vader he's
kind of like the emperor at least that's
the way they're presenting him in the TV
universe speaking of which Vandal Savage
the radiation also gave him a measure of
super strength super speed and it
evolved his brain just a little bit so I
would put his intelligence on the level
with eobard thawne but most of his evil
plans don't involve hard core technology
in the way that the reverse-flash is do
as you've seen like a lot of like the
animated movies he grows a cult-like
following turns them into an army uses
them to take over there was a storyline
a while ago where like a lot of his
abilities like his ability to regenerate
was diminished so he had to start going
around eating his children he does he
has many choke I mean he's grown up he
can have children he's had many of them
over the years they kind of did the same
thing with the ratio ghoul character
whereby he's had a number of children
that have grown and in lived normal
lifespans whereas he continues to be
functionally immortal so we may or may
not see some of the progeny of Vandal
Savage on legends of tomorrow but we'll
see how they deal with that I've always
wanted Felicity's dad to secretly be
like a big villain for arrow at some
point but if that's going to be the case
I think it'd be damian darhk-- too
because
they want a character that's more
central to arrows storyline and Vandal
Savage is kind of like a shared villain
speaking of which I don't know how
they'll be working together but Vandal
Savage will be working with the big bat
on the flash and the big bat on arrow
now we know damian darhk-- is the big
bat on arrow but we just learned that
zoom is the big bad for season two of
the flash in the comics Vandal Savage
has been associated with secret society
of super villains in Justice Society
Tartarus and demon Knights of all those
I think the closest we'll get to on
legends of tomorrow is secret society or
in Justice Society just the name secret
society sounds a little more realistic
so they might go with that or they might
not even call it that they might just
vaguely refer to some shadow
organization that vandal savage's the
head of now on the flip side the driving
force of legends of tomorrow is going to
be rip hunter fighting for the time
masters took to fix all the stuff that
vandal savage's doing through time and
space but vandal savage's biggest
nemesis in the comics is the immortal
man he's another person from the tribe
Vandal Savage was born to who later
after Vandal Savage did approach the
same meteorite and gained some of the
same powers I don't know if we're gonna
see him on legends of tomorrow but we
will probably see Vandal Savage touch
the meteorite like will see rip hunter
take the heroes back to vandal savage's
creation the moment he gained his powers
a lot of you guys have also price seed
my multiverse videos that I've done for
the flash season two
obviously the multiverse is a much
bigger context it's not only going to be
explored on the flash but Vandal Savage
started out on earth two before crisis
on Infinite Earths
that you mean the comics tend to change
backstories from time to time but during
that season 2 promo we hear Jay Garrick
say your world is in danger
he's from Earth too so he might also be
talking about Vandal Savage when he's
talking about zoom and as much as the
show is gonna be visiting big moments in
DC history we might get to see some
really cool Vandal Savage conquests when
he was living under other names he
claims that he is Alexander the great
Julius Caesar Vlad the Impaler
Blackbeard like he claims to be all
these really notorious figures from
history probably my favorite Vandal
Savage story though is something that
they might just completely sidestep if
you haven't read it it's called demon
Knights it's kind of like a version of
Marvel 1602 series that takes place way
way back in the past and the days of
Camelot
gets into a lot of mysticism and even
though arrow season four is like going
hardcore on mysticism
I don't know how crazy they'll get with
Vandal Savage and magic and for those
asking about Green Lantern stuff yes
Vandal Savage appeared for the first
time in Green Lantern number ten way way
back in the Golden Age they might do
some Easter eggs for Green Lantern but
Marc Guggenheim has made statements that
make it seem like they can't actually do
Green Lantern characters that doesn't
mean they won't refer to the Green
Lantern Corps but I mean I'm not
expecting to see how Jordan on screen
whenever arrow in the flash is done
really really big characters they
usually do something even if they change
the character a little bit they usually
do something that's true to their
original appearance in the comics the
last big storyline that Savage was a
part of was Trinity war where he tries
to take Pandora's box from her she gives
it to him but he can't open it because
he has like some some good in his heart
so he's not gonna be like your standard
mustache twirling villain I mean think
think about how a abarth on and Harrison
wells looked on the flash season one he
developed a genuine connection with team
flash like he actually cared for Cisco
even though he had a plan and he wasn't
gonna deviate from it like the way Tom
Cavanagh explains it the reverse flash
in season one you know he has he has
this mission he's not gonna let anything
get in his way
but that didn't stop him from growing
attached to Cisco like a son when he
said that before he ended up killing
Cisco he actually meant it as Tom
Cavanagh explains it so Vandal Savage
will be oppressing the earth not because
he hates it but because he loves it he's
going to crush you with all of his good
intentions as he cackles and shouts into
the sky so here's my big question for
you guys how do you want to see Vandal
Savage appear for the first time in that
flash versus arrow crossover like do you
want him to just kind of walk out of the
shadows or do you want it to be some
sort of flashback moment I'm kind of
surprised that they've revealed which
episode he was gonna appear in upfront
usually that's something that they saved
but it makes sense I mean we're gonna
see Hawkgirl before that will price the
Hawkman before that enrolling at your
big bat is historically something that
they do around mid season finale time
and if he's gonna be a shared villain
you might as well do them in the episode
where both casts work together remember
though that crossover episode is a
two-part episode like the first half
will take place on the flash the second
half will take place on
and it'll be episode 8 of both shows so
my next DC video will be that hawkman
video be sure to subscribe to get it I
have to do a Deadpool Q&A just for the
amazingness that that trailer was last
night so that'll be my next video then
after that I'll do that Hawk Band video
well use wait for that stuff to post you
can click here to watch the Deadpool
trailer again like 10 or 15 more times
and you can click here to learn all
about who the blue flash is thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you